Transcription: madjda rezig
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
J'ai envie de vous parler de dissonance.
Pour moi, la dissonance,
c’est une souffrance,
mais c’est aussi une chance.
J’ai travaillé pendant
une vingtaine d’années.
J’ai eu beaucoup de plaisir
dans une entreprise de la région.
Et puis, en juin 2020, j'ai été percuté
par une double dissonance.
Une dissonance d'abord personnelle.
C’était l’écart entre
ce que je faisais au quotidien
et mon sentiment d’urgence par rapport
à ce qu’on est en train de se dire.
Et puis aussi la dissonance
de mon entreprise
par rapport à sa trajectoire stratégique
et la trajectoire
qu’on aimerait qu’elle ait
si la planète était sa première priorité.
Alors, je me suis dit, comment
je pourrais être utile ?
Qu’est-ce qu’on peut faire
qui puisse faire bouger les lignes ?
J’ai eu un déclic au moment où j’ai vu
les travaux des 150 citoyens
de la Convention Citoyenne pour le Climat
et je me suis dit
que c’était la moindre des choses
que les entreprises prennent le relais.
Et donc est venu l’idée de la Convention
des Entreprises pour le Climat.
La Convention des Entreprises
pour le Climat, la CEC, c’est quoi ?
En fait, c’est d’abord un collectif
de 150 dirigeants d’entreprises
qui représentent tous ensemble
toutes les régions de France,
tous les secteurs d’activité,
et au total 75 milliards
de chiffre d’affaires.
Cette convention, c'est aussi un parcours.
Ils se sont engagés
à passer 12 jours pleins
pour la planète, six fois deux jours.
Ça a commencé en septembre 2021,
ça va se terminer
à la fin du mois de juin.
Et avant tout, c'est un parcours
de transformation.
Et le but de ce parcours, c’est de monter
les curseurs, d’être pleinement informé,
d’être pleinement équipé et engagé.
Avec la promesse qui a été faite
de proposer 150 feuilles de route
de redirection ambitieuse
pour faire un renversement
des modèles d’affaires
les intégrer dans les limites planétaires.
Ceux qui sont à l’entreprise
savent que le défi est énorme.
Et pour essayer de relever ce défi,
on essaye de réconcilier
la tête et le cœur.
Et donc, le premier jour de la convention,
on a eu une intervention
de Valérie Masson-Delmotte,
coprésidente du GIEC,
qui s’est adressée vraiment
avec des données scientifiques
à la tête des dirigeants d’entreprise.
Et puis, le jour deux,
on a eu un moment
plus de ressources intérieures
pour essayer de se réconcilier
avec soi-même.
Ça a été des moments assez magiques
qui se sont traduits
en fait le jour trois.
Et c’est une photo que j’aime regarder
pour me remotiver.
Par ce collectif, un élan collectif
de ces 150 dirigeants d’entreprise
qui sont, un samedi matin,
en train de travailler pour la planète.
En fait, le projet est il en train
de prendre de plus en plus d’ampleur ?
On a été auditionnés
à l’Assemblée Nationale.
On a des parcours qui s’organisent
dans différentes régions de France.
On est en train de préparer
le CSC au niveau européen.
Et finalement, je m’interroge
sur ce qui fait cet engouement,
en fait, le magnétisme de ce projet,
et je crois effectivement
que c’est la dissonance.
La dissonance, elle est partout,
en fait, elle est en chacun de nous.
Et en fait, cette dissonance, ça peut être
vu aussi comme une réserve d'énergie.
Parce que, quand on transforme
la dissonance en résonance,
Alors, à ce moment-là, on peut faire
de très grandes choses.
Voilà , c'est mon espoir
pour vous ce soir.